[Music]
Demetrius is next in Raleigh North
Carolina
hi Demetrius how are you you're trying
to be optimistic but not live what's
going on in 2015 I bought my wife an SUV
three months in it needed $1,500 repair
Lord and and that continued on up until
this point so so you've had a lot of
repairs on this lemon yeah and so was it
you get rid of it I was trying to stay
optimistic and now the cars dead it
needs a new engine which would be the
second new engine by the way good
gracious what kind of car is this it's a
it's a Volvo xc90 8 so what did you just
get a bad one or is that just a bad
brand a car or something
not bad I mean I was a good car but I
mean a bad modeler well we initially
thought it was a good car too because
that's all we've heard until we got one
okay and so now she's taking her hands
off it she's like you know this is your
problems you need to figure out how to
fix it this is going way down
I'm stuck me and I okay I'm so what do
you go to you all on this piece of crap
almost seven grand like 6,800 steps and
how many miles are got on it like a
hundred and comes with the new with the
new engine ask about the engine is about
the car how many miles as our got on it
150,000 but you put a brand new engine
in it how long ago no it wasn't it was a
brand new it was used oh you bought a
junkyard engine yes okay and what did
that cost you about $1,300 okay so you
get to do it again right yeah and then
you
right
well do I do it again
well you what you do is you use what's
the car worth today if it was running if
the engine as the last value I got on it
was from my bank and it was about five
grand okay jump on Kelley Blue Book and
look at kbb.com for private sale and
pretend like the engine was fine but
with the bazillion miles you have on it
and put in all the information and let's
say it comes back five thousand dollars
that's what the car is worth okay
running running if the engines were if
the engine can be put in for 1300 more
then take five thousand in your mind -
thirteen hundred and say that's the
least I could sell the car for salvage
and come out otherwise I got to fix it
to sell it fixed and so I'm thinking
salvage without the engine fixed that
this cars probably a two thousand dollar
car with the engine in it it's probably
a five thousand dollar car so it's
probably worth the thirteen hundred to
get it up to five grand you see what I'm
saying yeah because if you could get two
for it you're going to lose three
thousand dollars if you get five
thousand for it after you put a $1300
engine in it now you've only lost a few
thousand okay and that gets rid of it
it's all it's difficult sell salvage car
for much meaning with a bad engine in it
what's wrong with the engine completely
blow drop a rod and everything well
according to any it blew when my
children were in it on a trip on a five
hour trip so me and my wife had to go
and pick it up on the side of the road
so when we took it to the shop they said
it's it's low compression in three
cylinders which basically they said yes
once they yeah they figured that the
contributing factor was the person that
had the engine did not do the oil
maintenance they didn't keep up on all
maintenance yeah maybe so now now the
engine itself which is about the engine
and labor yeah you got low compression I
haven't worked I turn the wrench in
years but low compression on three
cylinders tells me it's blown I disagree
I mean I I mean I agree with everything
I'm
I'm not a mechanic but I think they
probably called that one right so yeah
you're buying a $1,300 engine and you're
gonna put it in the stupid car and then
you're gonna wave bye-bye as it drives
off down the street with this new owner
and you're still not gonna get much for
it because it's still a worn out car
it's got a almost 200,000 miles on it
and then it's on the second engine third
engine yeah what do I do with the
negative equity that I now have in the
vehicle because I'm not gonna get that I
mean I'm not gonna get nobody's gonna
I'm not gonna you have to have the money
to cover that do you have any cash no
okay do you have any credit where you go
borrow that well I have right now I was
thinking of purchasing another vehicle
and I got a pod for twelve thousand
dollar loan which I can purchase another
vehicle
you don't need another $12,000 loan you
need a lot less than that
we need a two thousand dollar loan to
cover the negative equity and we need
two thousand dollar loan to buy a car
until you get yourself out of debt
I get out of that car not one you keep
very long but we need to get you out of
debt you know I don't want you go
$12,000 in debt for a $1,300 problem
that's overreacting well I mean when
mama does her hands like that and goes
it's on you and she starts doing those
hands like that we all tend to do that
so I got you yeah but she's going to be
a grown-up too and she has she can
because what we want to do is we just
want to get pissed off and go buy
something and then we look back later
and go that's when I made the dumbest
decision of my life when I got pissed
off and bought something and you
frustrated with the whole stupid thing
and you just want to shoot the car with
a gun call the cops and tell them
somebody did that you know I mean it's
just blow it up or something right but
you get there I understand but you can't
do that you just got we got to do it we
got a handle a grown-up style fix it
sell it cover the negative equity get
your cheap car get the cheap car paid
off save up in car with cash
okay three-step program you got it man
you can do it it's just a pain in the
butt I understand I get it but one of my
things was I decided I was going to
drive junk long enough that I saved so
dadgum
much money that I never had to drive
junk again so I don't drive junk now cuz
I'm not broke anymore when I was broke I
drove crappiest old cars because I
didn't want to ever drive a crappy car
again see when you're broke you drive a
car that you have to give a name like
Bessie or Henry or old blue that's what
you do when you're broke so you never
have to again and those aren't the good
old days those old they suck those
aren't the good old days you look back
on those and go thank God we don't live
like that anymore you know those aren't
the good old days the good old days
include outdoor plumbing okay we don't
want the good old days the good old days
did we didn't have penicillin we don't
want the good old days I don't want them
I want I don't want to drive crap ever
again I don't want to live in a house
where things break all the time again I
want to have new enough stuff that it's
not breaking all the time and the way I
get there is I live like no one else so
that later I can live and give like no
one else you pay a price to win the
bible says no discipline seems Pleasant
at the time but it yields a harvest of
righteousness it's no fun to get there
but it's worth it cuz you get there